pay discrimination has gone on for too
long the principle of equal pay has been
in the treaty since 1957
but women are still being paid an
average of 16 percent less than men in
Europe this high time for further action
I will give a quality in the world of
work it's due attention by putting
forward proposals for pay transparency
the Commissioner wishes and visitors to
present a new gender equality strategy
in the first week of March I would be
looking at a broad range of options when
working on the scope of the pay
transparency proposals from giving
employees information on pay levels to
requiring companies to report on pay
levels and analyze such data in audits
the current gender pension gap in Europe
stance is over double the gender pay gap
at thirty five point seven percent just
think of the implications of that for
individual women for children for their
families as they grow older they just do
not have access to the same money to
live their lives is parked in hunting
and earth-quaking that gaytan marked and
things talk to him when the hdhd know
and fear of inside envoy when they sep
been dismissed and the Committee on the
apothem Mia as via PCR happen a state
legislative amass demand so long
transparent sanction on Matisse cremini
rule that is cremini own wound quandary
here in Chittagong the epical fanon does
have italians on his team coverage isn't
Santa's super Montella Cabrini has shown
no recipe with European legality to do
so prepared waswas choco new Samsung
edgy metro play more patek the toy will
need a medical plan
surely no pain lmho told it was axe
Palmilla hugs hospitals is a formation
solid a vinyasa if we yo a sukoon tax
resulta the music collective towards a
max de compañía de dos cosas para mismo
muy importantes no primero
hemos tenido una strategy appropiate
Pacific on brana's en específico de
lucha contra la Brisa Solari al kayfun
senado Pocoyo Grogan el marco de la
revisión rostra de aquella colas our
local indica burlesque La Rose para
poder la font RL phenomena y despues
vendor and estamos muy NGO semente spur
on Dora no a directive a soda
transparency ilaria Alcoa steadies yawn
yawn presentado me ah gustado el
contenido de lo que usted O'Dell
obligatory hacer auditory 'as de que los
empleados pueden Cano several assemblers
pueden conocer las escolhas al are a
less poor janeiro creo que es muy
importante Dom bien que teníamos un
regimen de son Sione's de protección de
las víctimas de la Brisa radial
important NSA NSA legislativa